thanks very much for having me i like to
say after one of these introductions my
refuge
it exceeds me so and in keeping with
that thread i'll say i like to start my
talks with a quote because as Oscar
Wilde noted quotation is a serviceable
substitute for wit the quote I'm going
to start you with is one of my favorites
it's from Edwin Schlossberg who said the
skill of writing is to create a context
in which other people can think and a
lot of what I've done in my career has
been to frame things in such a way that
people can see what's important about
them and what I'm going to try to do
today is to look at a couple of
interesting startups or projects and
pull out some of the things that I find
interesting about them as a way of
giving you some perspective both on
technology but also on values and
business strategy so the company that I
really want to talk about the most right
now is square and square is interesting
for a number of reasons but I want to
just ask how many of you have actually
shopped in a store that has a square
cash register so for fair number of you
how many of you have the square wallet
app running when you did that small a
number of you I really recommend it it's
pretty weird when you walk into the
store and they say a you Tim O'Reilly
you know obviously the clerk's needle
retraining because of course they should
be asking you what's your name you know
so that you have to provide then you get
two factor authentication instead
they're just looking at your name on the
cash register and you know you're facing
but still you look like yourself you're
probably ok but there are a number of
wonderful things lessons in this app and
I want to tease them apart the the first
one is to do less you know we hear a lot
in the mobile world about how it's a
small screen we hear about how people
use mobile devices differently but this
something that's incredibly important
that's going on in mobile that I think
we're just beginning to
and that is that your mobile device
knows so much that you don't have to
tell it as much as you used to you know
I'm an investor in Foursquare but i
still think how stupid is it that i have
to check in somewhere I mean my phone
already knows I'm there I'm an investor
in RunKeeper but I see why do I have to
tell my phone that I started running it
knows I started running it knows when I
stopped and one of the things that i
love about square is that Jack has
exploited this you know when you show up
in that store you know you're if you're
running the square wallet app your
identity is broadcast to any square cash
registers now if you talk to a merchant
you'll say oh yeah sometimes we get
people who are in the next door over
it's not like a real check in but the
fact is you know jack figured out I
don't actually have to ask the user to
tell you know me that they're there the
phone tells the cash register that it's
in the vicinity without any human
intervention other than starting the app
and running in the background now there
may be some battery issues with that so
on but you think about that as a trend
and a theme that you've got to come to
grips with in designing apps you know we
now have devices that have so much
information so much implicit context and
there's going to be I think a revolution
as we take away more and more of the
instructions that we give to the device
and realize oh wait we can just assume
that so first lesson second lesson of
course from square is that you have to
embrace hardware as well as software
Brad Feld who is a technology investor
from Colorado made a humorous comment at
our make hardware innovation summit last
year which sounded very retro until you
thought about it he said I'm not
interested investing in software anymore
i'm only interested investing in
software if it's wrapped in plastic yeah
which made you think he was referring to
shrink wrap software but no no he was
referring to you know that somebody had
figured out some maker element do you
know whether it's 50 a Fitbit or square
whatever
but there was a clever bit of hardware
hackery that square used up front to
bootstrap its business to make a phone
into a credit card reader you know that
thing actually listens it actually uses
the the audio jack for input to the
device very very clever bit of hardware
hackery and there's no power and the
thing you know there's a lot of maker
smarts in that device as well as
software smarts the third lesson that
you see in square is the notion of
software above the level of a single
device you know we're so used to
thinking of you know the software is
being what's running here now we've been
in this transition really for a you know
decade decade and a half and we're just
getting deeper and deeper and deeper
into understanding what this means the
line softer above the level the single
device actually came from Dave Stutz is
parting letter to Microsoft when he
resigned must have been about two
thousand three or two thousand four and
he said stop looking over your shoulder
you know there's plenty of money to be
made building software above the level
of a single device the name the term
stuck with me because at the time I was
giving a series of talks called the
open-source paradigm shift and it was
really about the real implications of
Linux because everybody was still at
that time thing oh wait Linux is in
competition with Windows and I was like
no no you guys are missing the point and
I would ask audience as I say how many
of you in the audience use linux and I
get a show of hands you know depending
on where i was talking you know very
many or very few and then I would say
well how many of you use Google and
every hand of the room would go up and I
say well then you use Linux it's just
not on the computer in front of you you
know and so trying to get across the
notion that the computer that was in
front of you was not the only one but
what's really interesting is that we're
starting to see with applications like
square literally someone has designed a
system that you know is in the space
between these devices between the app in
your pocket and the
cash register app on the at the front
desk of the coffee shop or the local
merchant and that notion is again
something I think we're going to be
seeing more and more as a design pattern
how do you think through you know a
whole set of interactions between users
who might be on different devices and
you know obviously there's a software
backend that has that credit card
information that has that picture you
know when you when you there there's a
lot going on there and it's a system
it's not just a single application so
you know a fourth lesson harness network
effects in data you know this was the
heart of you know my thinking that came
out of that open source activism was
when I realized that you know was
actually something clay Christensen
called the law of conservation of
attractive profits I realized that open
source software and open protocols of
the internet we're going to make
software as it was less valuable and
something else would become valuable
when that became commoditized and I came
to the conclusion it was data and you
know so that was really what
distinguished companies like Google or
for that matter amazon from the previous
generation of software companies and but
you know this is a key part of square as
well I remember when I first talked to
Jack about the application he was saying
well we're going to use you dose ppl
social network to help with credit
scoring and obviously they're retaining
data in the form of people's credit card
information their pictures all these
kinds of things that are required and
that application really is going to get
better and stronger the more people are
part of the network so network effects
in data is a critical piece again of
what makes square a really interesting
and paradigmatic app you know the fifth
lesson that I take from square is to
rethink workflows and the experience
that someone has you know again you know
so many apps you know that experience is
this you know that's not very
interesting experience you know the
experience of walking up to a you know a
storefront and talking with a person
with while the devices are doing this
work in the background is the complete
rethinking of that of that workflow but
another place where you see this also in
a retail context is in the apple store I
mean how amazing is the apple store you
go into a typical retailer you can't
find a salesperson to save your life you
know and instead you know what Apple has
done is they've given all these they've
taken that cash register workflow and
totally decomposed it so that everybody
who works for apple in the store can
check you out they can check inventory
they've turned them into augmented
humans with superpowers you know you
have instead of no clerks you here's
automation you know creating more clerks
and making it an extraordinarily
profitable store and I think this model
can be applied in other areas i was in a
brainstorming session run by the markle
foundation with todd park who's the
federal CTO he was a time CTO of
Department of Health and Human Services
and he was talking about how walgreens
is trying to do this for pharmacy
assistants where they're trying to get
them a you know to be able to be more
helpful to people because they have
access via a phone to you know the
database that will basically make maybe
a home health assistant somebody who has
superpowers you know rather than this
being a low level job it becomes a high
level job when you give that person
access to the machine and I think this
is really perhaps one of the most
interesting things about Google Glasses
it will allow more of these kinds of
workflow innovations where you know
people are going to be able to be
connected to computers in more powerful
ways in a professional setting you know
so a lot of people say well Wow will
this be weird they think about all the
consumer applications but this is a huge
set of applications in purely
professional settings where you're
really going to be able to rethink the
workflow how somebody does
their job because they have access to a
computer in a different way so there's
another lesson that sort of implied in
all of those just last examples which is
really to think differently about
man-machine symbiosis you know one of
the key ideas that I had when I was sort
of promulgating the idea of web 20 was
that it was about harnessing collective
intelligence that what distinguished the
apps that survived the dot-com bust from
those that didn't was that you know
companies like Google and Amazon were
really good at figuring out how to get
their users to contribute to what they
did you know I could go into that in
great detail but over the last decade we
found more and more interesting ways to
do that and there was a wonderful paper
by JCR Licklider written in 1960 called
man-machine symbiosis I updated called
human machine symbiosis fits as we not
quite so sexist now oh we still have a
long way to go but you know he was just
talking about this possibility of you
know connecting humans and computers in
new ways and so I you know a really
great example of this that I can't you
know passed by is the the Google
autonomous you know car what I find so
fascinating about this project is that
you know in 2005 it was we had the darpa
grand challenge and the winner went
seven miles in seven hours you know six
years later google says oh we have a car
driven hundreds of thousands of miles
norden area traffic what happened what
was different and there was a wonderful
line from peter norvig he said we don't
have better algorithms we just have more
data and what was that data it turns out
it was the google street view vehicle so
the difference is the recorded memory of
humans who drove those roads you quit
humans with sensors very very detailed
sensors that measured everything that
photographed everything collected all
that data stored in the
global brain and then you know returned
it you know for use by that car that's a
brilliant you know rethinking of
man-machine symbiosis human machine
symbiosis there's similar examples in
robotic surgery but you know really
fascinating Peter made the comment it's
you know it's a fairly hard AI problem
to pick a traffic light out of a video
stream it's a trivial AI problem to
figure out this red or green if you
already know that it's there and that's
really that one of the one of the key
insights that went into that vehicle and
again so that's something you ought to
think about so but back on this notion
of since we're on the subject of cars
you know another application that you
know puts a bunch of these principles
into work you know softer above the
level of a single device is uber and
rethinking workflows you know think
about that wonderful experience you've
got a phone it knows where you are the
drivers got a phone and those where he
is or she is and then uber has this you
know memory this brain which is
identifying that routing telling
everybody how to get together that's a
system its software above the single
level of a single device it's providing
a whole lot of context without you
having to do a whole lot you know when
you when you first checking it Hoover
does a decent job of figuring out where
you are maybe you have to correct it a
little bit they've done a pretty good
job of applying these principles but
there's another principle that uber
brings up kind of a really interesting
thing you know when you use uber you're
asked to rate the driver the driver is
also asked to rate you as a passenger
now that's a really really interesting
thing and uber is pretty ruthless about
weeding out people who get bad marks
from their passengers now you think
about your experience of if how many
people here have actually driven in an
uber fair number is pretty good
experience isn't it it's kind of one of
those magical
things like going into you know a square
enabled coffee shop or going into an
apple store you go whoa this is really
good you know and you compare that to
your experience with it with a cab
driver you know you have you know the
guys you're playing loud music he
doesn't know where he's going you know
all kinds of terrible experiences you
know you get new / driver does that
they're out on their ear and you think
about the old-school way that you know
taxicabs are regularly well we're going
to test people we're going to figure out
who is approved to do this you know uber
is actually done one better you know
there may be some regulatory issues
there that need attention but there's a
lot of ways that we're starting to see
reputation systems that we've seen on
internet applications start to have
relevance in the real world and I think
that's I'm not putting that as a
principle I'm just asking it as a
question I think it's one of the great
interesting unanswered questions in the
government area but the lessons my next
lesson that I really wanted to highlight
from uber is to close the loop you know
what makes that uber experience so
different is that you know when your cab
is going to arrive you know when when
you let's say you want to go to the
airport and you call a cab you never
know are they going to show up are they
close you know did they forget you know
you're standing on a street corner in
the rain you don't know how long it's
going to be think about uber you know
you can sit in the restaurant you can
sit in the coffee shop you get a text
when the driver is outside you know uber
has closed the loop you want to know
where they are you can actually look on
the map and you can watch their progress
towards your location you know uber has
closed the loop and I got that framing
from Chris Sacca who's an early investor
in uber he was also Google's head of
special projects for a long time and he
said what i learned from google is to
only invest in things that close the
loop I think that's a really really
important principle and if you're doing
a start-up think about what loops
you can change that's another piece of
you know how do you make things smarter
so that if you know you don't have these
open ended systems where you don't
really know what you're going to get so
but I want to return a little bit to
square for my next lesson which is a
slogan that we've used a lot at o'reilly
create more value than you capture you
know think about when Jack first started
square he had a social mission in mind
he wanted to enable a class of small
merchant who he felt was disadvantaged
who couldn't take credit cards he wanted
to enable anybody to exchange money in a
new way he was thinking hard about how
do you actually make the economy work
better that's you know a big interesting
question and one that I think we miss a
lot we have a lot of startups that all
they're really thinking about is you
know how do i get a startup that will
get funded and get me to an exit you
know and maybe you think well i have an
interesting problem but you know this is
the kind of thing you know my sense was
that Jack wanted to solve that problem
whether you know it turned into a big
business or not he just thought was
really really interesting to solve and
but this also this so sense of trying to
enable an economy that feels really
important and this is quote that I love
from leigh misery habla and it's so
wonderful i how many people do you how
many people saw the movie okay I've seen
the play whatever how many people read
the book even better the book is
absolutely wonderful probably my
favorite novel of all time but the the
story for those of you didn't know is
the guy who was a prisoner for many
years he was in prison for stealing a
loaf of bread yeah like so many people
in our prison system he you know he's
kind of he's ruined by this he becomes
sort of a criminal he gets out
he can't get a job because he's branded
as a criminal he ends up stealing some
candlesticks from a church that takes
him in and the AH be there instead of
turning me in to the police when the
police come around he says oh no I gave
them to him and so Jean Valjean becomes
he sort of feels like he has an
obligation to do good after this and he
goes and he becomes a businessman and he
creates this wonderful hit of this
factory where he builds this wonderful
business and this is the line that I
love so much he makes the entire region
prosperous so there was no pocket so
obscure that it had not a little money
in it no dwelling so lowly that there
was not some little joy within it and
here's this key point father Madeleine
he's living under student him because he
was an escaped con so father Madeleine
made his fortune but a singular thing in
a simple man of business did not seem as
though that were his chief care he
appeared to be thinking much of others
and a little of himself now you know you
think about how many people in business
that you could say that of there are not
that many and that's something really
wrong with that and I think it really
started with you know this idea which
came out in the 80s that the only
obligation of a business is to make
money for its shareholders we've seen
where that has taken us you know to a
situation where the wall street banks
can think it's perfectly legitimate to
screw over the entire economy as long as
it fattens their profits this is not
okay it's the big lie of modern business
you have an obligation if you're in
business to create value that's one of
the the lines that I use all the time is
that we should create more value than we
capture but this idea that Jack had that
he wanted to build something that helped
the economy that help the small business
and you see this in in etsy you see it
an Airbnb they want to figure out how to
make an economy they want Pete other
people to succeed as a result of this
you see it in kickstarter obviously so
these are really important lessons you
know if you're creating an ecosystem if
you're creating value for other people
your business will succeed you know I
didn't coin that line we made a model
for a Riley it was actually a guy named
Brian Irwin who was that time my VP of
Marketing we had a management retreat
his back 10 12 years ago we were just
talking about so key principles at
o'reilly and you know i mentioned that
you know some number of internet
billionaires who said oh yeah it all
started with an a Riley book and I
laughs nice to yeah I got that and I got
30 bucks for it and he said yeah that's
one of our one of our guiding principles
create more value than you capture and
I've loved it ever since because it's
such a great idea you know if you could
make other people successful if you can
do what father Madeleine did in in the
miserable you can make the world a
better place you're really you know
doing a good thing so now that kind of
another way of saying the same thing
would be this other principle that I
have which is simply to work on stuff
that matters and we'll talk a bit more
about that in a moment but I want to
lead up to another principle just by
reflecting very briefly on some of the
things I've been associated with open
source movement web 20 the maker
movement open data open government these
are all in a lot of ways things that
matter there are also big ideas that
told a story and that was what I wanted
to come to is this as a tenth principle
for you if she's idealism is not only
good for your business not only good for
the world it's the best marketing you
know when we started working on the open
source movement it was because we said
hey this is really important thing that
nobody's paying attention to it but we
sold a lot of books because we told the
big story that mattered to all those
communities that we made them proud of
who they were they we made the world
know who they were and it was great
marketing for us it was great because we
were helping others and we helped our
own business web to know a lot of people
don't realize this but the reason why we
started that marketing campaign was
because after the.com bust a lot of our
customers were out of work and we
actually had our strategic goal in 2003
to reignite enthusiasm in the computer
business we basically we went out there
and we told a big story that was
designed to help other people and it
sure it helped us build our business as
well you know clearly i've been doing
that in areas like open government i'm
looking at health care i'm really
interested in that but there's another
element of that idealism that I want to
share and I want to start with a talk I
gave in 2008 called why I love hackers
and it was at our emerging technologies
conference and in that talk i gave i
read a poem and you can't really see in
the background it's a painting by
Delacroix in the background of Jacob
wrestling with the angel it's a biblical
story and the poem by Rilke is about you
know how the wrestlers of the Old
Testament would go wrestle with the
angel and they knew they couldn't win
but they got stronger by wrestling with
the angel and and it's wonderful line
from milky says what we fight with is so
small and when we win it makes us small
what we want is to be defeated
decisively by successively greater
beings and I love that and I so I told
this and it was funny because the
reaction from the audience with people
love to be challenged with idealism they
love to be challenged to do stuff that
matters and so in the last you know ever
since I gave that talk I've really just
been focusing on that just like I don't
care what you do do something that
matters to you more than money that's a
great way to succeed but even if you
don't succeed the world will be in a
better place and and that's what you
should think of as an entrepreneur and
you think about working on things that
are hard remember that what we fight
with is so small when we win it makes a
small you know find hard problems
thinking of a great example of this p.s
up my son-in-law had started a company
called Makani power which does high
altitude wind energy and one of the
things that first of all
really hard problem but what really
stuck in my mind was a guy who quit a
hedge fund to come work for Makani it's
basically pretty hard you're basically
controlling you know a flying drone that
is generating power has to be able to
fly autonomously for your years at a
time you know or else you come up and
down at least at a very controlled way
but the guy said you know I quit working
the hedge fund to come work here because
the math is harder you know and that
spirit that spirit of somebody who says
I want to come work on a hard problem I
don't want to work on stuff that's easy
that's one that I find really exciting
and and you know working on stuff that
matters may mean doing a start-up like
mechanic can also do mean nonprofit
kinds of things I've been very involved
with an organization called Code for
America which tries to get people like
you to go give your service working with
city governments working to make better
interfaces for government I think
government is a really important part of
our economy important part of our
society it's clearly broken we need to
take responsibility for fixing it coach
America is doing a lot of that one of
the projects that were working on this
year I was designed to describe by
swimming and Milgram as money balling
criminal justice turns out that one of
the biggest cost for cities is pretrial
incarceration this is you know sort of
prison industrial complex which profits
from keeping people in jail cities are
really kind of stuck here because
there's all this fear monger who can you
let out and the bail system is really
broken it was originally designed to let
out the petty criminals keep the big
guys you know behind bars but of course
the big guys are profitable enough that
the bail bondsman will put up a bond for
them the little guys can't come up with
the five-hundred-dollar bail and they
end up rotting in jail turns out you're
more likely to be actually be sent to
jail if you come into your court
appearance as a prisoner than if you
come in from the outside you lose your
job because your hell all these kinds of
things and in fact many these people
could be released on their own
recognizance this group called the
Arnold foundation has built a data model
that actually helps to predict who's
safe to let out and you know the project
that we're doing in New York City and
Louisville is actually to apply that
aight a model build an app for judges
and we'll see how that works but the
story that i wanted to share the fellows
just were out there and they were in
louisville and the louisville fellows as
part of their that you know they kind of
go to the city they studied the problem
they got booked into jail and this is a
in a really amazing story that they're
you know being escorted through their
cell because they've kind of gone
through the whole process and some
prisoner calls out hey warden who you
know who are your new friends you know
and and she says you know these are the
coach from America fellows and the guy
is that young prisoner he says oh my god
it's the code for america fellows
they're here to fix it they're here to
fix this as like boy what a burden you
know it's like oh they're kind of like
oh crap are we going to be able to do
that but the fact that you know and you
start telling them all things that gone
wrong during his you know that's so
powerful when you can have that impact
you know there's so many problems where
you have impact on people's live so
anyway if any of you are interested go
to coach from America org and look for
the fellows application there's also
something called the White House
presidential innovation fellows which is
trying to do the same kind of thing at
the federal level where they're looking
for talented people to come work on on
problems of government so they're also
in their application cycle right now
finally I just I think there's a lot of
huge opportunities in healthcare but
this also started up opportunities gen
Palka who founded Code for America
really wonderful posts on linkedin
recently about a startup idea that the
two of us have batted around for a long
time which is yeah how would you enable
the small corner store with logistics
with whatever to basically give them
some of the same buying power as a
Walmart predictive analytics about what
people will buy there's all kinds of
interesting things you could do to
reinvigorate and reinvent the corner
store kind of social business but also a
big business opportunity so with that
since this is a I'm going to end with a
little bit of self-promotion in addition
to doing o'reilly media and a variety of
associated business we do have an early
stage venture for
O'Reilly alpha tech ventures Oh a TV com
and if any of you are interested in
doing or are doing startups that have
that apply the kinds of things I'm
talking about here or particularly do
things that are going to make a big
difference in this world I want to hear
from you so I'm Tim at o'reilly com or
at Tim O'Reilly on Twitter so with that
I'm going to open it up for questions
thank you all right thank you very much
is very careful and my question is a
thousands of years versus honoring the
ecosystems in terms of the internet
ecosystem because that people predicted
throw themselves like up empty in being
a standard make a stop limit order based
on their platform so I'm curious how
about the interactive in terms of the
room on the whole ecosystem to make me
do some pepper pilots buscar
yes and the autumn between the what
camilla duchess and the order yes yeah I
mean for example oh okay sorry god what
a sad continues Athena ecosystem play
their game in their own way yeah so how
to deposit it interacting with each
other the ecosystem and is there any
party you do fully dedicate to beautiful
well I guess what I would say let me
start by repeating the question it to
the extent i understand it there's a
balance when you are building an
ecosystem between you know the central
party that is controlling that ecosystem
and then the various other players how
do you design the ecosystem as a whole
and and and and the question i would
just say it's an ongoing process you
think about for example the web
ecosystem you know and all the problems
we have with web spam with SEO spam you
know google has to work constantly to
make sure that they're thinking okay how
do we improve results but they can make
decisions that say we're going to favor
a certain kind of project over another
we're going to pay attention to certain
kinds of signal we're going to try to
give a priority to whatever we think are
the best results for users not the best
results for advertisers for example and
you see this in something like Airbnb
where they have ideas about how they
want to support the experience of their
providers do you think about it with you
know etsy where they're favoring small
sellers they're trying they're trying
not to encourage you know big big
players to join the ecosystem you see it
clearly with Kickstarter where their
funding certain kinds of projects and
not others managing an ecosystem i think
is really really important because
companies that don't get that right
I think lose their edge ebay was a great
example they started favoring the big
sellers did really well for them for a
while but it took away a lot of the
vitality of that ecosystem of course
created opportunity for somebody like
Etsy but also add amazon for that matter
okay I butt down here so my question is
really like gorillas open source
business models and I feel like your rep
added you have proven their relatively
viable but really like it's a question
because of my foot matter things said
like okay sourcing our platforms
completely insane but I think that it
could make a lot of sense if if it were
license right and i think my example to
them was like you guys give away your
books gr and free but you still happen
to make money on them and so there's
anything you could seem to like about
that alright so the question is about
open source business models and how you
make money when you're giving away your
product for free let me point out a
couple of things here first i do think
that the biggest open source success
stories were not people like red hat
they were people who actually built and
sold services they used open source and
obviously is obvious lunch of obvious
players google in amazon yeah facebook
twitter they're all open source
companies that took open source they use
it to deliver a service but this is even
more direct example the entire web
hosting business you know very thin skin
of selling dns as a service selling
wordpress as a service selling you know
web you know selling apache as a service
you have for a subscription fee you know
and so there's a pretty clear case where
there was an open source business model
it was sitting in plain sight that
didn't look like the business model of
you know a software company and i think
it's really important to look a little
sideways it was a wonderful talk at our
open source convention once by a guy
named Robert Lefkowitz is by the name
Rommel and
he basically started in with this long
conversation about sharia compliant
mortgages which is you know under Islam
you can't you can't loan money so he
said basically that you know the Islamic
banks he went through the two or three
different ways that they get around this
you know they basically rent you your
house for 30 years at the end of 30
years they make a gift of it to you you
know and so they kind of explains this a
nice is ok so now let me show you the
pnl for borland versus the pnl for red
hat he says look yeah the percentages
are identical all the way down the line
there's only one difference this line
says licenses and this line says
subscriptions you know sharia-compliant
mortgage he basically Red Hat it was the
same business of Berlin and you know so
when you think about open source I think
the most important thing think about is
where do you get your business advantage
now there are open source business
models where you get your business
advantage because hey I at least in the
early days this is a great way to get my
software in people's hands but in the
era of cloud that's actually not really
much of an advantage anymore because
anybody can get their software in other
people's hands you know so that's really
gone and you know that was the idea for
mysql and the whole idea of of dual
licensing you know we'll build the
market by letting anybody use it and
then we'll upsell from there but today
that it's probably easier to do that
with a cloud app than it is with with
open source so you have to think i think
a little bit harder about where you get
your business advantage and why you want
to open source it you might want to get
contribution from users I don't know
anything about your business a huge way
to do it is is that this some other
network effect that comes into play as a
result of your software either you get a
network effect because lots and lots of
people use it or because it produces
data that you are actually going to
monetize is another so there are a lot
of a lot of answers but I would just
urge you to think sideways and don't get
caught in open source being a
simple variation on a business model
where I would have charged you know and
I would have had a proprietary fee but
yeah so I I don't know what the right
answer is for you maybe we can talk more
about that later okay let's go up to the
back up there oh hi my name is Desmond
from Philadelphia so I'm actually
working on a project called code for
philly which is basically for not good
for America yeah but in the East Coast
we don't really have as big community of
Hector and open sort before so my
question is do you have any suggestions
to bring to make the community of Hector
and open-source glad you'll feel better
oh gosh I would have said this a pretty
good open source community in
Philadelphia but you know better than I
do hahaha so yeah the thing I would say
is find interesting problems that are
relevant locally and you know work on
them work on them publicly talked about
them this wonderful line that dave winer
once said about blogging and its its
significance for business which is it's
about narrating your work in public so
narrate your work in public you know
make sure that you tell the story of
what you're doing why you're doing it
and keep telling that story until you
get other people to come with you now
keep in mind that sometimes it takes a
long time you know I think if some of
the movements that I've been associated
with you know it takes a long time we
launched make magazine in 2004 right and
it's only now that you know the VCS are
all over it what's that eight years you
know you know I started talking about
this idea of data and that you know
trans you know the real business model
of open source being these network
effects and data and what became cloud
again it's start talking about that in
1997 you know and you know that we were
building an Internet operating system I
and I get you hit a conference called
building the internet operating system
in 2001 everybody said what the hell are
you talking about you know so just keep
at it over here great so speaking of
stories
tell us your story and you've had a
really long a lot drink where were you
stationed how how I became Tim O'Reilly
so my initial III got out of college and
I didn't want to have a job simple as
that I I had this notion that I wanted
to you know have interesting work but I
didn't want to be you know constrained I
wanted to build kind of lifestyle
business and in some ways I joked that
O'Reilly was just a lifestyle business
that got out of control you know my
initial business my initial business
plan was interesting work for
interesting people and it was no more
than that and what we did originally was
a tech writing consulting company but I
started getting asked to write manuals
for the same kinds of products and so I
started retaining the rights you know
these are things like oh wow you want a
Fortran manual we've already got one and
it will sell to you and then and then
that turned into the publishing company
because we realized that we originally
selling directly to companies you know
so you know we'd lice Italy we're a
documentation company we say okay you
can pass $25,000 and have it in six
weeks instead of fifty thousand dollars
and have it in six months but then we
realized that people were more excited
to actually buy individual copies and
the big turning point in our business
was a Sun Microsystems had turned us
down on a twenty-five-thousand-dollar
license fee for our x window system
excellent programming books and then a
year later they bought a million dollars
worth of printed copies of the same
books and we went okay wait and but but
again when we really thought about that
it actually made sense because when we
sent sold them a source license they had
to go manufacturer you know tens of
thousands of copies of these things and
this is in the day when you know you'd
print out you know companies would print
out their manuals on a dot matrix
printer and put it in a binder and it
costs them the same amount of
as buying the individual copies from so
it was actually not as crazy as it
looked so again getting a little deeper
I think into you know your your
customers problems is a really important
part of understanding of business you
know we launched our conference business
because it was that really actually
because of a Microsoft ad campaign I
think was in 1997 when they were about
promoting something technology called
activex and they actually had television
commercials and Andrew Schulman who was
a who was working for me at the time had
done a lot of books about Microsoft
technologies that said that in this
particular ad campaign all of the sort
of activate the internet things that
they were demonstrating in in the ad
were done with pearl except for this one
little animated taxi cab which was the
activex kanino control and I was sort of
a little I sort of pissed off about that
and I and I decided and this came at the
same time as the book pirate borders had
told me that programming pearl had been
one of the top 100 books in any category
at borders that you know preceding year
so I went whoa I nobody's talking about
pearl so I'm going to do that and I
watched my you know pearl conference
really just to promote pearl ago nobody
is not getting any respect I turned into
a really good business so then we
launched the open source convention and
then went from there to realize that
organizing conferences was a great way
to help promote the technologies and
ideas we cared about you know you know
somewhere along the line we realized wow
we could invest in some of these things
so we launched a venture firm you know
so we just kind of you know there was
probably a big turning point for me was
around 2000 i think i read the book
built to last by collins and champy and
i remember we talked about great
companies having big hairy audacious
goals and you know i SAT there and I
said what what what ties everything that
I do together and what I wrote down was
changing the world by spreading the
knowledge of innovators and that helped
us realize that we weren't just a
publishing company that we really were
about finding interesting people finding
interesting ideas and amplifying them
and you know drives everything from
are you know the businesses that we're
into the marketing that we do and we're
always looking for those ideas and those
transformations by the way up a book
that I would recommend it's an e book
that I read recently that is really
helpful in this regard is it's by
Michael shurig called who do you want
your customers to become it's really
worth thinking about he makes the point
that really great companies have an idea
about transforming the lives of their
customers you know here the examples he
give for example you know Henry Ford you
know didn't just invent the assembly
line he invented the driver you know he
invented the weekend so people would
have time to go drive cars he and that
yeah they're all these ways that he
thought about changing you know people
and you think about how you know the
iphone isn't just a piece of technology
the smartphone has changed who we are
google changed who we are google didn't
just change a search create a search
engine they created you know a
population of people who take for
granted that they can find anything they
need to know and that's a really really
powerful idea and so we've been sitting
there at a Riley trying to think about
this say what are we trying to change
what we trying to change them into is
that's another piece of this sort of
thinking about big ideas think you know
when I say changing the world by
spreading the knowledge of innovators
that people have these important ideas
and I want I want the world to go in
important new better directions and so I
look for interesting problems and I
basically try to do a lot of mostly I do
a lot of lazy web stuff to get other
people to do all the hard work to make
the changes that I'd like to see happen
there's actually a wonderful point in it
was at our emerging technology
conference and quinn norton wrote a
piece i forget what it was in and with
us in for it was in some some you know
fairly rare field magazine she said I
finally understand Tim O'Reilly if he
wanted a jet car he would give a talk
about how wonderful jet cars are and how
we real
need them yeah and it is very true
because there's so many things that I
want to see happen yes why through in
that bodega 2.0 slide of Jan's and we're
kind of like we want this to happen you
know let's hope we can inspire some
entrepreneur to do it yeah okay over
here my name is Evan my question is or
where do you think well the marriage
between digital media and online
advertising will be going in the next 10
years in digital media where will ever
media and alma and I see okay we're
trained digital media online advertising
well i guess i would say it's not so
much a marriage as it is a sort of an
ongoing affair but I you know back in
1994 I wrote I give a series of talks
and I wrote it down eventually paper
called publishing models for internet
commerce and I think we've had this long
dalliance with advertising as the
primary business model for online and I
think we're really starting to realize
it's not the only one back then I said I
thought the publishing industry had
actually a great deal to teach the
internet they had lots and lots of
business models crazy business models I
mean you know there's actually a kind of
business that harnesses school children
to go around and you know sell magazine
subscriptions that was publishers
clearinghouse remember those guys if
there still exists or not you know you
know this sort of crazy stuff that we're
starting we're going to discover so I
think we're going to get way beyond
advertising where you seen it
subscription is really big and that was
one of the reasons you know when we
launch Safari Books Online into
thousands like subscription is going to
become a really important you know
business model we should we should place
a bet on it you know pay-per-view I mean
that's really what downloadable ebooks
are our apps and so I think we're
starting to see we now have you know
three or four great business models for
Internet content digital media you know
pay-per-view subscription and
vertising guess what they're all there
in the print publishing business as well
and I think we're going to see others as
well okay let's come here so I was the
option of the current Attorney about
open source hardware fix all so-called
makers revolutions and how you can see
scandal works in class and as what
you're talking about the words will
change the workflow of the room and
forest directions how can we find the
eunuch of annual you've got campus
campus computing needs oh the all
services or products yeah so let me talk
you the question is really what do I
think about the maker movement and you
know the opportunities there and I guess
I would say a couple of things and the
first is that the maker movement has a
lot hidden inside of it and the first
thing you have to look at is up the arc
of new technologies every new technology
starts with a maker movement you know i
mean the homebrew Computer Club the you
know the early World Wide Web everybody
was role in their own right and it turns
into a big business you know and and so
it's really important to understand the
maker movement first of all as a stage
of the industry and you know and it has
this characteristic that as soon as it
becomes mainstream people don't see this
maker anymore you know so a great
example of this is multi touch displays
you know I remember back in 2005 we were
showing off a tower ii tech conference
yo Danny Hillis is map table which was
yeah this giant table he built for the
you know the air force or the CIA or
somebody that you could do all those
things on you know and then it was jeff
hahn 2006 he's there at yeah Ted and our
a tech conference showing his home brew
multi-touch display which actually later
he turned it into a company and sold the
ocn
and when you see them up there doing
that's a perceptive pixel display but
freaking 2007 it turns into a an iphone
nobody thinks of multi-touch as a maker
thing it was only two years from being a
maker thing to being in the hands of
millions of people and I think we're
going to see a lot of technologies that
were but we call maker now they'll just
be like hey that's consumer electronics
so that's the first thing I would say
there but there are some very very deep
lessons in the maker movement the first
is this notion that i talked about here
about how sensors are becoming part of
everything and how hard we're in forum
software and how it's going to change
the nature of the interfaces when you
have devices that actually have their
own sensorium so that that's one then
then there's the other big wing which is
yet manufacturing being perhaps
democratized in some profound ways
whether it's through 3d printing or
whether it's through low-cost reusable
you know hardware platforms or whether
it's through access to manufacturing you
know in China and and then this i guess
i would say finally this what you know
GE is calling the industrial internet
which is applying all these principles
to really big pieces of equipment yeah
so this is a lot going on there and it
will have a massive impact on business
it already is so back there back there
in the middle yeah sooo
I'm a huge fan of what you're doing with
governments you find out I'd love to
know your perspective where should
people start when creating a
conversation government good other thing
yeah new opportunities specifically I'm
from San Diego and our transit system is
broken I'm curiously if i were to say
start that conversation but with what
does good trends % you more like where
you started yeah you know I don't know
the question again is when you're
working in the open government context
where do you start and it's it's I would
say it's it's hard to know the way that
I've always tried to do it do whatever I
do is you tell the story of people who
are doing things right and you hope that
there's somebody out there listening who
says I want to be like that you know so
you say wow they're doing really great
stuff in Portland here's what it looks
like they're doing really great stuff
over here you know in New York you know
whatever it might be wherever it might
be and you try to you know talk that up
and and hopefully by holding up the
torch you get some moss to come out
towards the flame and then you got them
so there may be other ways but they're
very labor-intensive finding the right
person in a bureaucratic organization
you know I what I've tried to do you
know is simply to celebrate success talk
about you know what the future might
look like and then you you find the
people who care and you get enough of
them you start to get some attention but
there are practical things you can do
you know you you know with code from
America you know that's actually been a
strategy for finding it you know the
smart people in cities we have an
application process and we say yet we're
looking for forward-looking cities who
want to engage with us around projects
you were increasingly thinking about you
know particular areas we want to work in
and and it just take takes time and you
know footwork there a lot there are a
lot more civic startups my friend Ron
booga name whose works with us on the
code from Eric accelerators raising a
gov tech fund
King for civic startups so there's a lot
going on there okay last question here
you're sitting there in the middle even
raising your hand a lot so where do you
see the future of conferences in the
next ten years and what has been your
most delightful experience with
principal Robbie all right what do I see
a future of conferences over the next
ten years I'm not very good at
predicting the future despite what
people say I just talk about what's
happening in the present that seems
interesting to me and I go by william
gibson's dictum that the future is here
it's just not evenly distributed yet so
what do I see right now about
conferences that are super interesting
well clearly you've got to pay attention
to the fact that ted has syndicated its
conference out into the world that's
hugely interesting second you have to
look at the success of something like
foo camp which is our original
unconference who's then copy by barcamp
which is against spread all around the
world the idea of self organizing
conferences where you bring in
interesting people and you know they
develop their own program is hugely
important I think there's a really
interesting thing happening with a kind
of festival as opposed to a conference
whether it's open co which john battelle
launched recently or things like the
XOXO festival for kickstarter that was
done in portland you know I au festival
in Minneapolis is sort of a really
interesting how do you create a
community happening rather than just a
professional conference I think people
still like to get together I don't think
conferences are going away I do think
that they have to become much less of
talking heads on stage and much more
more interactive and certainly my to the
other part that last part of the
question my own sort of experience with
foo camp you know probably the best I
can't think of what would be the best
move moment but i will certainly think
of you know when people when you bring
people together and they walk away and
they do something
as a result of the introduction you made
that's that's a pretty good feeling
probably probably the most important
thing I would say about my work is the
greatest satisfaction i have is giving
ideas to people and then seeing them do
something with why thank you join me
you